-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-winning
writer and director
whose films include
"Inglourious Basterds,"
"Kill Bill," and "Pulp Fiction."
His book, "Cinema Speculation,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
Quentin Tarantino, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Good to be back.
-This is a wonderful book
because it is both
a collection of
film criticism about movies
that are important to you,
but it also has this
great personal element
about you falling in love
with movies as a kid.
And a lot of the movies
were introduced to you
at an age-inappropriate time.
-Well, "inappropriate"
is a fluid term,
depending on who
they're talking about.
But the movies were not intended
for children, alright?
-Yes, I guess that's
a good way to say it, yeah.
-They were not
intended for children.
And the thing is, they were
also -- It's the very --
It's the very beginning
of the '70s,
so movies have exploded
because of the ratings board.
Movies have -- Just actually so
the audience knows,
part of the thing is, before the
ratings board came out,
there was --
One, there was the Hays Code,
but the other thing about
before the ratings code is,
if you made a touchy movie,
be it sexuality or violence
or any kind of thing like that,
you could be sued
by any sheriff in
a jerk-water county
who said you broke
their county's obscenity laws.
-Right.
-So the ratings board, you know,
once they came about --
that became the law of the land.
So, consequently,
movies just kind of exploded
when it came to
graphic subject matter,
like I say, either sexuality,
violence, or disturbing stories.
-Do you remember
the first disturbing thing
you saw that
made an impact on you?
-I saw -- There was
a movie about Isadora Duncan
that was directed, the British
director, Karel Reisz
called "Isadora,"
and it starred Vanessa Redgrave
playing Isadora Duncan.
So, the ending is --
she's in the back of a roadster
and she's wearing this
long, flowing scarf
that's just hanging down.
And -- "Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!"
They're driving around.
I think she even has a champagne
glass in her hand.
"Ha, ha, ha!"
And then the scarf gets caught
in the wheel of the roadster
and...
strangles her to death.
-And this was not a movie
where there was any sense
that this was going to be
the ending.
-No.
-Not a horror film at all.
-No, no, no, not at all.
In fact, I'm sure
that one of the reasons
it made such an impression is
I was so thoroughly bored
by the movie up
until that moment,
until that happened, alright?
I'm like...
You know,
and so, on the ride home,
my parents were driving me home.
So I'm just full of questions
about dying by your scarf
getting caught
in the wheels of a car.
-Yeah.
-And it's like
this major concern.
All of a sudden,
I'm so afraid of this.
And my mom says, "Quentin,
you have nothing to worry about.
I would never, ever,
under any circumstances,
let you wear
a long, flowing scarf
in a convertible roadster."
Whew!
-Now, I feel like less
with movies, more with comedies,
my parents introduced me
to things
that my peers had
not been introduced to.
-Yeah, yeah.
But that makes sense, actually.
-And then the teachers, though,
maybe they
catch onto this, right?
Were you sort of the person that
disseminated these adult films
and their plots
to your classmates?
-No. There was this aspect --
Usually, one other kid
that was allowed to see
the contraband stuff.
-Yeah.
-There was this thing where
I'd go see a movie,
and then I'd go
back to school and, like,
spill the goods on this
wild contraband stuff.
And, usually, the kids --
Not always,
because I saw a lot of stuff,
but, oftentimes, they even knew
what the movie was
because they showed TV spots.
-Yeah, so they'd know
the trailer, right.
-One of the better times
as far as that was concerned was
my mother -- Again,
this is like, ah, the '70s.
They used to have
things like this.
All of a sudden,
out of the blue,
they would have --
United Artists --
not just like one theater.
United Artists would, citywide,
do a big release of three
Woody Allen movies.
-Uh-huh.
-And, so, it was "Bananas"
and "Everything You Always
Wanted to Know About Sex
(But Were Afraid to Ask)"
and "Sleeper."
And, so -- And my mom wasn't
even a Woody Allen fan.
And, so, I asked her,
could we go,
like, on a "school night,"
no less,
and she goes, "Yeah."
I cuoldn't believe she said yes,
but she said yes.
And, like,
the three Woody Allen movies,
and she doesn't like
Woody Allen, alright?
That was really nice of her.
-She's very -- Sounds lovely.
-She's really cool, alright?
And, so, we go to the movie,
and then there's everything --
Again, imagining a child
watching this.
You're watching "Everything You
Always Wanted to Know About Sex
(But Were Afraid to Ask),"
and there's the monster-movie
parody about the giant boob
that's, you know,
going across the countryside.
-Like "The Blob."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But it's just a big -- It's
a big boob, a big tit, alright?
You know?
And it squirts milk, no less.
-Yep.
-Well, you can imagine how
I'm regaling the kids at school
the next -- "I saw a movie
that had a giant boob.
And it drowned people with
milk."
In fact, I think the line
was, "The cream slowed him down,
and the milk killed him."
-You -- One of
the great things is,
you write about movies,
and not only do you write about
"This is my take on the movie,
this is what I loved about it,"
but you also sometimes have
a lot of knowledge
of how the movie was made,
choices that were --
casting and who the director was
and who the script was.
Did you find it was
difficult to figure out how to
combine those two things,
both your personal taste
and your personal experience
of knowing about the backstory?
-Well, that was actually
one of the fun things
about writing the book.
It was as thing that made it
similar to me writing fiction,
where the thing about it is,
with fiction,
I have a really good idea
about where I'm going to go
with some of this stuff,
but at some point,
I want the characters
to take it from me, you know,
and start writing some of
the stuff itself
so I'm actually almost,
like, dictating it.
And, to some degree,
when I got into
my own arguments
with myself on the page,
that started happening.
But then one of the things was,
I hadn't thought that
I would be have -- I wouldn't
call what I do journalism,
but I didn't think I was
going to have that much
backing up, other than
my own general knowledge
of how a movie was made.
But then, like, I'm doing
"The Getaway" chapter,
and I go, "Well, I'm actually
friends with Walter Hill,
and he wrote the script.
He was there for everything.
Let me give him a call."
And I give him a call,
and he just --
he's a wealth of information.
Not only is -- You know,
he's a terrific writer.
He's proud of the movie,
but he's a great raconteur.
And he was there.
He was there for
every moment of it.
And, so, he tells me
this amazing story
that I didn't even really know.
And then I was able to back
that up with this,
and he's the one that said,
"Why don't you give
Steve McQueen's ex-wife,
Neile McQueen, a call?
You don't really know
how important she was
to McQueen's success."
You know, and,
so, I give her a call,
and she's this amazing raconteur
and has a fantastic memory,
you know, and tells me
all this stuff.
And so it was
one of those situations
where if I didn't just
have a point,
i.e. my own relationship
with a movie,
or if I didn't want to
just do analysis,
I knew that was
another way to get in
was to just go through
like, a verbal history,
an oral history
of how the movie was made.
-It's really -- Every sort of
section of the book
has this really nice dimension
to it because of that.
I'm wondering,
as you write film criticism,
what is your relationship
to the way
people write about your films?
Like, even when people don't
like things I've done,
I always do appreciate
when they take the time to
sort of drill down.
Is that how
you feel about critics?
Like, what is your --
Do you like reading reviews
of your work?
-Oh, yeah, no, I read them all.
I read them all.
Look, I really know my movie
really well, alright, you know?
So were there were a case that
somebody could shine a light on
me that I couldn't see
on my own --
They might not like it.
They might not appreciate
what I'm doing.
But at the end of the day --
And this is
an easy thing to say,
but, truly, most of the time,
well, I didn't really make
the movie for those people.
You know,
I made it for somebody else.
-Yeah.
-And -- But, also,
I've made movies where
I've had fans that give
good reviews of my movies,
and they don't like this one.
Well, that doesn't mean
they're right either.
But, also, it can just also
not be for you.
But I'm actually --
It's less of a situation of,
"Oh, hey, they're going to
tell me something about myself
I don't know."
That can happen,
and that has happened.
But it's more,
"Oh, this is the conversation
that's happening
about the movie."
And that's kind of important,
because there really only is
a conversation about the movie
when it comes out.
-Yep.
-After that, it -- You know,
all those newspapers
are in birdcages,
and no one remembers anything.
And the perception of
the industry, of the fans,
of everybody is kind of set.
Now, it can change, usually,
over the course of time,
but the conversation
about the movie,
good, bad, or indifferent,
is what's important.
-I think it's really special
that you wrote this book that,
for the people who are going to
take the time to read this,
it's going to start
conversations about these movies
that I think, otherwise,
for this generation,
would forget.
And so that's a cool thing
you did that,
and it's great to
see you, as always.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Oh, my pleasure, man.
My pleasure.
-Quentin Tarantino.
"Cinema Speculation" is out now.
We'll be right back with
Emily Ratajkowski.